so i wonder though in pennsylvania with
you've said people are right
rightfully suspicious we did talk a
little bit before the show but i'm
wondering if you think there was fraud
or if you've seen anything well i would
say that there are
there are there are definite anomalies
there are definite irregularities and
just today
i i saw what looks to be pretty
compelling evidence
of voter fraud uh a combination of voter
fraud and ballot harvesting
in nursing homes in beaver county now
beaver county is a hundred percent
in my district and we noticed
actually i it was the republican
chairman of beaver county his name is
jim
uh christiana along with the sheriff
tony guy two great
great people uh they noticed that there
were a lot of people in nursing homes in
beaver county that had requested a
ballot filled out a ballot and returned
it on the same day
now that was a sort of an anomaly is it
is that wait how do you how do you
request it then get it on the same day
well i'm gonna send it to you i mean
maybe somebody delivers the ballots and
people fill it out but
no but like if if you request it did
someone just
run over like yeah make a phone call i'd
like about and they run and give it to
you yes
well yeah yes yes and so that was
suspicious
in fact that's in the beaver county
times you can probably you can look it
up you could find the article with jim
christiana talks about uh the nursing
homes
um and and so he he did a sort of uh
freedom of information
uh request and requested 2 000 ballots
from those nursing homes and what he
found immediately
uh tim was that like all of the
signatures match
all of the handwriting was the same and
obviously of the four nursing home
facilities that he looked at now that
the handwriting matches were in batches
but these were all these were all union
controlled nursing homes where the
signatures and the handwriting was
exactly
the same wow and i've seen i've seen it
with my own two eyes today
uh with with you know with tony guy and
jim christiana uh
they showed this stuff to me today and
so look
i'm not saying that that that is fraud
but i can tell you that we're going to
pass that to the
u.s attorney of the western district of
the western district of pennsylvania
and we're going to let them decide we're
going to let them do an investigation is
is it frau is it is it definitively
fraud i mean without an investigation
having been conducted i mean i'd
i'll be careful with my words i don't
know but so i actually i pulled it up
i pulled up it's time's online and it
says uh uh
beaver county nursing homes christiana
questions mail in belgium
they mentioned there's two thousand mail
in ballots following uh you know strange
pattern
uh questionable patterns these patterns
require the next step to be a review of
the outside envelope see if there's any
forgery
and that's what we looked at that's what
i'm talking about that's those are the
2000 ballots that i saw today
the handwriting is the same there are
forgeries of signatures
so that sounds like harvesting and i'm
telling you right now there's there's no
question in my mind
it's it's it's i've seen the handwriting
i've seen the signatures
it's it's there's no question in my mind
that what jim christiana has
he's reviewed those two thousand ballots
he's looking so who who is he he's a
republican he's the republican chairman
of beaver county and along with tony guy
who is the sheriff out in beaufort
county so what have you done with the
evidence
we just look we just he he called me jim
called me about this last night
told me about it last night showed me
the evidence this morning
and what what jim is going to do
along with with tony again who is who is
the sheriff is
in all likelihood turned the evidence
over to the
the district attorney dave lozier out
and beaver county another great human
being
uh and they're going to pass that
information to the uh u.s attorney and
the western district professionals
yes absolutely absolutely you know look
again this
if we aren't talking about this stuff
right now it never comes to light and
the likelihood of it happening again
is very high people the people have a
right to know
if this stuff is happening is is it can
i say on the show
with 100 certainty that that's voter
fraud no
because there's not been an
investigation done but i'm a human being
that that can
put two and two together all the
handwriting is exactly the same
and you've seen them i've seen them so
and it's going to u.s attorneys
yes all right well my concern is i don't
know if they're going to do anything
and then i don't trust them well well so
dave lozer and the district attorney uh
they're the district attorney dave
lozier and and then
uh the uh the the u.s attorney they're
both great human beings i trust them
i trust them scott brady is the u.s
attorney in western pennsylvania they're
good people
all right um i trust them but here's the
deal
a criminal investigation of something
like this is gonna take a long time
will that impact the outcome of the 2020
election i don't know
well it's only 2 000 votes well that's
but there are
there are something like eight
nine total we only look at four wow
eight or nine total nursing homes
and that's just in and around the beaver
county area and that doesn't even count
allegheny county
which is where 80 i would say probably
80 percent of
of the vote comes from in pa 17. so what
this could do
like look what if we start expanding
uh uh an investigation into other
nursing home facilities how many votes
would that mean now i
i don't know if that's gonna be enough
to affect the presidential right
but it could but it will affect down
ballot congressional races and down
ballot state house and senate races
absolutely so should we look into that
absolutely we
absolutely should i would i would
imagine if you find
widespread fraud or harvesting which is
i believe would still be fraud
then at a certain point you're not going
to have the time to actually investigate
every single nursing home
you'd have to just i don't know cancel
the election
because if you're finding widespread
fraud here's the problem okay
to clarify i know the left is going to
be like how dare you
there's no there's no solution there's
none there is no solution to this
problem we have we have reached an
impasse where no matter what you do
you're going to set off
tens of millions of people it sounds
like based on what i read
about your lawsuit you it sounds like
you're correct i'm not a lawyer
but based on the stories that i read and
going through it your lawsuit about the
constitutionality of mail and ballots
yeah sounds like they couldn't do that
sounds like they knew they couldn't and
they tried
changing some words to get around it and
that creates a problem where
now the democrats are saying we won and
you're saying uh this is the
republican's fault
the republicans passed this this act 77.
yeah and it's now it's screwing over i
am careful to say it's their fault
because again tim i mean there are laws
that are passed that are
unconstitutional that are on the books
for years and we don't realize that
they're unconstitutional
uh work for years later so my my point
is this is how our system of government
is intended to work
sometimes we don't always know if a law
is unconstitutional or not and that's
why we rely on the courts i
don't i don't mean like it was
intentional but it is their fault if
they passed a law that was
unconstitutional and it causes problems
with the election
where it's got to be thrown out ballots
are well well the
the but let's not let governor wolf off
the han
and how about the attorney general like
the attorney general
who is also a democrat uh josh shapiro
should have probably caught it before it
was passed yeah but you know do you know
do you know why do you know why they
didn't
you know why in their attacks on me
which they've all
like every democrat in the state of
pennsylvania and believe me they they've
fired up their base they've
i've had death threats my attorneys have
had death threats about this wow
it is not about it is not about throwing
out 2.5 million
mail-in ballots the demo people who cast
a mail-in ballot
and thought that the system was
legitimate and then act 77 was
constitutional this is not about that
for me
as much as the media would want to write
those sensationalist headlines and
the left is attacking me for for wanting
to throw out those ballots that's not
true
but you'll notice in their attacks
they're not addressing whether
right 77 is constitutional so so so
annie's
it sounds like we're at a point where
it's these ballots are no good the
election was no good in a lot of ways
there's
potential even fraud we pulled up the
beaver county times and it sounds like
there's strange
goings on here's the way here's the way
i describe it you're walking down the
street
and you see a building smoke alarms
going off all right what does a smoke
alarm mean
usually means there's a fire you don't
see smoke you just hear the alarm
so we call 9-1-1 figuratively and we say
hey we're hearing alarm go off and the
response we get is
do you have evidence of widespread fire
no but the smoke alarm is going off and
they're like well we only come out if
there's evidence of widespread no no no
when i hear the smoke alarm you come out
to check if there's fire
so if we're seeing these anomalies these
signatures these stacks of ballots
the fbi has to come in or whichever
agency
and actually launch an investigation
they better do it pdq because we have
deadlines
and then the problem is if they don't
and now now we're getting reports we're
gonna have these hearings in three
states
they're if these hearings you we
actually get hard evidence presented
they're going to go over affidavits and
and i'll tell you during the michigan
certification hearings
we had a guy call and rattle off a list
of evidence of impropriety and potential
fraud
and they ignore it what's going to
happen then if you don't investigate
is all the legal challenges saying you
were made aware of this
you didn't investigate we want an
injunction and then what's what
if the courts this is what people need
to realize is that courts are humans
and so even if something is technically
correct they might not allow it it comes
down to the judge
so there was a uh one of the one of the
cases trump lost the judge basically
said
you're right but we're not going to
disenfranchise so in the future we'll
just do it better
that's called yeah that's called
prospective and i'm not a lawyer but
that's called perspective relief and so
that could be one of the scenarios in
this lawsuit with acts 77 they could say
yeah 2020 was
was foobar right but let's do it better
in the future and i can't
we can't do it the thing is is that i
would be okay with that but we
the country wouldn't 73 74 million trump
voters would say
no if they say right now in any capacity
that this is unconstitutional but we're
going to let it stand
it's going to be i don't even know how
to describe what's going to happen well
here's the thing i don't see
i i don't i don't see a court
well i i just don't know i don't know
how i we've asked the court
for help with a remedy right because
that's the way our system of government
is
is supposed to function we hope that
they
that they step in and grant some sort of
relief now the governor
uh was not we weren't anticipating him
certifying the result of the election
today
he did it just hours before we were
supposed to uh
be heard um heard in in in a
not a hearing or a court it was like a
telephone call phone conference thing or
whatever again i'm not saying
yeah i don't know what the hell they do
i'm not i'm not a lawyer but um
but he certified the results of the
election
and and during that time
the electronic filing system for the
commonwealth court of pennsylvania was
down
so like what do you what do you do i i
feel like
you've always got to err on the side of
um
some kind of remedy against some kind of
system against impropriety or
malicious intent if there's a
certification process
and the electronic file system goes down
then the court should be like nope
no certification because you can't have
you know emergency court filings being
blocked or unable to process while
someone's slipping through
some major you know yeah and and tim we
weren't asking the court to block
certification to overturn an election
we were blocking certification so that
we it would give us time to make our
argument
right and again we we were hoping
to have time to make an argument to to
the court
uh and have them give some sort of
decision or remedy as to what to do
uh with acts 77 because again we believe
that it disenfranchised all voters not
just people that mailed in a ballot
disenfranchised all voters
this is going to have serious impacts on
the uh the presidential election itself
we'll see i mean like you said it's it's
explosive
right and courts are are comprised of of
human beings and
i i just don't know but i i will tell
you this
that i believe that acts 77 is
unconstitutional and on the merits i
don't think that
anyone can deny that it just is
you can't change the entire electoral
system in pennsylvania without a
constitutional amendment that simply was
not done
i mean for a lot of other states i would
imagine it's the same thing
or similar in some capacity i can't i i
was like i was mentioning earlier
surprised to just you know
when they were making all these sweeping
changes to hear that courts were
agreeing with it
11th hour election changes and of course
democrats were very much okay with it
and you mentioned this to me on the show
when
you came in the first time that well
they believe it's going to help them
absolutely it's it's that that if
democrat
believe me when i tell you if democrats
thought that mail and balloting would
disproportionately help republicans
they would be so against it you know and
so
so here here's the interesting thing
about that the pa state constitution
there is like an emergency provision
where the governor and the legislature
could invoke some sort of emergency
power uh to uh
overhaul an election system in the
middle of an emergency like a pandemic
to keep people safe but they didn't do
it
so why you know what's crazy to me is uh
watching
in michigan you see what happened with
michigan certification oh with uh
yeah first you had wayne county yeah
where so i
republicans got threat they didn't want
to certify and then there were
threats family threats and then they
certified one dude said
your kids probably go to this school
yeah it's like right away someone's
gonna be like please stop i'll just sign
whatever you want
and then after the fact they signed
sworn affidavits saying they were send
their votes
and they were like too bad it's too late
you can't do anything and it's just it's
the stupidest thing because
what people need people need to
understand is that we don't live in a
computer
we're a country composed of people
meaning if there's a p
here's what people don't get about like
contracts right they have this
movie-esque understanding of how
contract law works where it's like
if i take out a piece of paper and says
sean parnell signs over all of his
assets to me
sign it it's not going to hold up in
court the judge is going to be get out
of here like that's not a real contract
you know
people people think oh but you signed it
it's so when it comes to
you know what happened in michigan you
could have a hearing and the judge can
be like no
it's a good point they were getting
threats we can clearly see the threats
that's not a legitimate document you
can't put someone under duress to get
them to sign a document and have it
be upheld in court especially when you
can clearly prove it the crazy thing
about michigan
is that i was watching the actual
hearing they had when i went to the
state board of canvassers
and one of these guys name is like aaron
van van
lengeveld i think his name is was just
absolutely ignoring
the the evidence presented or i should
say this you know
claims of evidence that people were
calling and saying here's here's the
document here's the individual here's
the law
and no matter what anyone said to him he
was like
i have to certify nope nope one guy read
him the law like 10
times and he's like it says for any
necessary purpose
to certify meaning to ascertain the
truthfulness you can adjourn he goes
i can't do that sorry so that it's it's
crazy to me
watching this republican be like nope
there's literally nothing to say
i'll ignore the law i will ignore what's
presented to us
and i'm just gonna do it and now they're
certifying in michigan
and then you have in pennsylvania with
you i i was surprised certification even
happened so cause i was like tracking
i'm like
i was on the phone with my attorney when
it happened i'm like oh they just
certified pennsylvania he's like what
yeah so it just and they did it because
they knew
that once it was certified it'd be a
little bit more difficult
for us to proceed with with the case on
on an emergency basis
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you